In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion for August 23rd, on which we commemorate the Holy
Hyromarter, Irenaeus, Bishop of Lyon, our Holy and God-bearing Father, Irenaeus, who was
providentially given the name Peace, Irenaeus, to be a messenger of the Holy Spirit, was
born in Asia Minor in about the year 140.
In his earthly youth, he had followed in Smyrna the teaching of the elderly bishop, Polly
Carp, who passed on the tradition of the Holy Apostle, John.
He thus learned to hold faithfully to the apostolic tradition handed on in the church.
It is the church, he taught, that God has placed the apostles, prophets, and doctors, and
all the Holy Spirit's other operations.
Even this Spirit are, therefore, excluded all who, refusing to turn to the church, to
prive themselves of life by their false doctrine and depraved actions.
For there where the church is, there also is the Spirit of God, and there where the Spirit
of God is, there is the church, and every kind of grace, and the Spirit is truth.
After having stayed in Rome, he became a priest of the Church of Lyon in Gaul.
During the persecution by Marcus Aurelius, circa the year 177, it was a presbyter of this
church that he was entrusted with taking to the Pope Eleftherios in Rome.
The wonderful letter, which the Holy martyrs of Lyon addressed to the Christians of Asia
and Frigia, describing their glorious battles to refute mountainouss' heretical sect,
is indeed the preeminent testimony to the truth, the sign of the victory of the Spirit
over the flesh, and the pledge of our hope in the resurrection.
On his return to Lyon, Irenaeus succeeded St. Fortinos, who had just been martyred at the
head of the churches of Lyon and Vienna.
As a bishop, having received through holy tradition the sure charisma of truth to proclaim
and interpret the gospel, he then s forth devoted his life to the witnessing in imitation
of the martyrs to this truth.
We must love with an extreme zeal that which is the church, and take firmhold of the tradition
of the truth he taught.
He toiled with unfailing energy to convert the barbarian people to the faith, but his
solicitude also extended to the whole church.
He wrote to Pope Victor in the year 189-198 in the name of the bishops of Gaul, whose primate
he was, to dissuade him from breaking communion with the churches of Asia, which celebrated
the feast of Easter on the 14th day of Nisan.
As this ancient custom had been handed down by our ancestors, who no less kept the peace
with one another, he maintained that there was no necessity to impose uniformity as the
difference in fasting confirms the unity of the faith.
It was particularly in the battle against the heresies that he became known, most especially
against the falsely-named Noces, which from Asia Minor had spread through all the chief
cities of the empire and had seduced many people with its esoteric doctrines.
The struggle against the Nostics allowed the holy bishop to paint a vast picture of Christian
doctrine.
He showed that this Noces, which the heretics vainly sought in the mythical plots and complicated
constructions of their perverted intelligence, is the preeminent gift of the charity that
the Holy Spirit gives to the Christian in the living organism of the church.
It is only within it that one can quench one's thirst with the clear water that flows from
the side of Christ, thence to receive life-eternal.
All other doctrines are nothing but broken sisters.
The true Nostics are not those who reject and despise the body to worship God, ineffable
and his demurege, but spiritual men who have received from the Holy Spirit the earnest
of the resurrection of the body and of incorruptibility.
Breaking with the Hellenic duality of body and soul, St. Irenaeus developed St. John's doctrine
of the word made flesh to interpret the meaning of the vocation of man.
The first Adam had been formed from clay by the two hands of God, the word and the spirit
in the image of God, conformed to the model of the glorious flesh of Christ, and the breath of
life had been given him in order to progress from the image to the likeness of God.
Having been tricked by the devil, jealous of his prerogatives, and having fallen into death,
he had not, however, been abandoned by God, who had from all eternity intended to make him a
partaker in his glory. The revelations and prophecies of the Old Testament and above all the
incarnation of the word, his death, his resurrection, and his glorious ascension constitute the necessary
stages in this economy of the history of salvation. Always keeping in mind this ultimate end for which
he had created man, the word was made flesh, recapitulating the first Adam in himself.
As the first man born into the Virgin Earth fell through the Virgin Eve's disobedience by a tree.
So Christ came into the world through the obedience of the Virgin Mary and had been hung on the tree of
the cross. He gave his soul for our souls and his flesh for our flesh, and he has poured out the spirit
of the Father to bring about the union and communion of God with men, bringing God down into men
by the Spirit, and drawing men up to God by his incarnation.
The word of God, who had created the world, invisibly making it in the form of a cross,
made himself visible at the time appointed on the cross. In order to bring together
in his body all the beings that had become separated and bring them to the knowledge of God.
Appearing not in his ineffable glory, but as a man, he has shown in himself the restored image
of God, conformed once more to the likeness. He has nourished us at the breast of his flesh so that
accustomed to eating and drinking the word of God and strengthened by the bread of immortality,
we might draw near to the vision of God that gives us incorruptibility.
It is impossible to live separated from life, and there is no life without participation in God,
and this participation in God consists in seeing God and enjoying His sweetness.
For the glory of God is the living man, and man's life is the vision of God.
For Irenaeus, a disciple of those who had known the Apostle, knowledge,
noses is love, and the deification of man in the person of Christ the Savior.
Much more than a simple refutation of false noses, his doctrine, wonderful in its simplicity
and profundity contains the seed of all that the later fathers developed in their inspired writings.
After his piece-making intervention with Pope Victor, Irenaeus continued the work of confirming
the Church. It is said that he died a martyr during the persecution by Septimus Severus in about
the year 202. But no details on the circumstances of his death have been preserved.
His body was placed in the crypt of the Church of St. John, which then took his name
between the tombs of the Holy Martyrs, Epipodus, and Alexander through the prayers of our Holy
Fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us, and save us.